in großbritannien heißt es bei boris
london lebt der britische premier bei
stolzen ist zurückgetreten jonsson tritt
als vorsitzender der konservativen
zurück will aber bis herbst
premierminister bleiben vor wenigen
minuten sagte er in der downing street
10 es ist eindeutig der wille der
parlamentarischen konservativen partei
dass es einen neuen parteivorsitzenden
und damit einen neuen premierminister
geben soll der rücktritt er hat sich
angekündigt innerhalb von nur zwei tagen
waren mehr als 50 abgeordnete aus seinen
eigenen reihen selbst zurückgetreten aus
protest schauen wir nach london denn da
gab es einen ganz besonderen moment als
boris johnson heraus kam hörte man nur
buhrufe
schauen wir zu dir ja wischnewski diesem
moment für uns verfolgt hat julia wie
ist es mittlerweile bei dir
[Musik]
ja also die berufe waren ja jetzt
wirklich über minuten zuhören während
boris johnson seinen rücktritt verkündet
hat und dann auch noch danach jetzt so
langsam lichtet sich hier die menge
etwas aber man sieht immer noch menschen
mit vielen plakaten motors steht bei
borealis boris johnson der lügner raus
mit boris aus unserer demokratie also
soja diese negative stimmung das
negative image von boris johnson unter
dem fitness auf jeden fall zu spüren und
das hat man auch mit den hufen hier
gemerkt rund um die downing street als
er sein rücktritt gerade vorhin
verkündet hat troja konntest du mit den
menschen dort vor ort sprechen was war
so für sie der ausschlaggebende punkt
dass sie jetzt dort hingekommen sind mit
buhrufen mit schildern dass sie eben
wollten das vor stolzen jetzt
zurücktritt dass sie ihn eben nicht mehr
den rücken stärken
ja ich glaube einfach so genug ist genug
es gab so viele momente in den letzten
monaten so viele skandale rund um boris
johnson rund um die minister rund um
soja dieses ganze kabinett von ihm das
einfach jetzt die menschen sagen so wenn
nicht jetzt wann dann und das hat er ja
offensichtlich jetzt auch gemerkt diesen
druck dem er einfach nur nicht mehr
standhalten konnte und deswegen ist er
jetzt heute offiziell zurückgetreten und
ich denke auch die menschen kommen
hierher um eben zu sagen wir sind hier
weil es reicht ja es ist nicht mehr nur
genug auf social media zu posten oder
irgendwie auf twitter sich zu äußern
sondern man muss vor ort sein um noch
einmal zu sagen bei das letze basics
vielen dank julia für deine eindrücke
dort von vor ort und wir müssen über
dieses thema natürlich weiter sprechen
unser bild chefreporter peter titel ist
bei uns im studio peter wie hast du bois
tanzen heute wahrgenommen jetzt radja
wieder sehr selbstbewusst aus so kennt
man ihn mit großem ego geht er davor die
presse vor diese bürgerinnen bürger dort
in london wie hast du diesen autos von
ihm wahrgenommen also 5 meter um
branchenübergreifend niemand platz wenn
der auftritt also so groß ist da ist das
ego und das kann er auch und damit hat
er die briten auch begeistert und man
darf nicht vergessen wenn es buhrufe in
london gibt geht man raus aus den
docklands geht man in die docklands geht
man nach erstes raus dann ist die
stimmung in großbritannien eine völlig
andere als in dieser babbel london das
war auch boris johnson das
erfolgsgeheimnis das war es schon
während der praxis abstimmung da hat er
die kampagne angeführt raus aus der eu
2016 und das ist sein erfolgsgeheimnis
das brauchst johnson unglaublich bei den
leuten populär ist bei den einfachen
leuten mit paul johnson kannst du dir
vorstellen im pub zu saufen und
schmutzige witze zu erzählen so ein typ
ist das also einer mit dicken ellbogen
wird ein riesen ego und heute natürlich
musste er natürlich seine riesengroßen
niederlage nach nur drei jahren im amt
überspielen da auch darin ist er
europameister im rausgehen und sachen
weglächeln funktioniert nur diesmal
nicht diesmal musste er seine eigenen
niederlage freundlich verkaufen gut
verkaufen bemerkenswert für mich ist er
sich an genau zwei völker gewand nämlich
einmal an seine briten an großbritannien
an die leute dort und dann auch an die
ukraine denn das darf man nicht
vergessen war ein problem wie die briten
mit ihm haben oder die er in
großbritannien hat und jemand in
großbritannien alle verhandeln muss ist
boris johnson einer der wichtigsten
unterstützer der ukraine im krieg den
russland gegen das land führt und an die
ukraine hat das nicht noch mal extra
gewandt und das ist dann doch wieder
bemerkenswert dass es der andere boris
johnson der dann auch haltung
empathischer typ ist mir schon noch
einmal ganz kurz rein in seinem
statement ganze sechs minuten hat er
gesprochen und seinen rücktritt erklärt
und er hat gekämpft er hat an seinem amt
festhalten wollen am ende hat es dann
doch nichts genutzt
laut uwe boll
[Applaus]
die screen aldi will otto parlament drei
künstler wie die party-queen
julia marty new players die anzeichen
dass jemand anders premierminister
und cranberry und ich haben uns geeinigt
dass dieser prozess jetzt angestoßen
werden sollen und das wird wie folgt
aussehen nächste woche werden wir ganz
klar fest machen wann was geschehen wird
und jetzt werde ich einige posten nennen
bevor mein eigener re tritt finalisiert
wird vielen von ihnen möchte ich sagen
vielen millionen die für uns gestimmt
haben danke dass die konservativ gewählt
haben danke für die größte konservative
mehrheit seit
1987 ein ganz besonderer erfolg
millionen von ihnen haben für uns
bestimmt dafür danke ich ihnen der grund
warum ich so hart gekämpft habe in den
letzten tagen im amt zu bleiben
ja es ist schmerzhaft für ihn gewesen
das hat er nochmal betont ist es
schmerzhaft eben damit mit seiner
politik nicht erfolgreich gewesen zu
sein peter was war denn so
ausschlaggebend jetzt für diesen
rücktritt vielleicht kannst du das noch
mal einmal für unsere zuschauer
erläutern also zu viele skandale zu
viele lügen zu wenig rückhalt das ist
die einfache formel darüber dass boris
johnson dann am ende gestürzt heute
morgen ist sind new statesman das ist
eine britische politik zeitschrift mit
einer karikatur auf dem titel erschienen
boris johnson mit der lügen nase von
pinocchio und die abbrennen der nase
also da war nicht mehr viel platz bronze
und so viel gelogen zu viele skandale
gehabt und ausschlaggebend dann am ende
war tatsächlich dass er dann noch
beschuldigt wurde nach einem privaten
skandalen anderen skandalen die er
wirklich hat er hat versucht
parteifreunde vor juristischen schritten
zu bewahren er hat spendengelder
missbraucht für die sanierung oder für
die modernisierung seines dienstsitzes
elend lange latte aber zum schluss hat
ist bekannt geworden dass er einen
konservativen abgeordneten in sein
kabinett geholt hat zu seinem vater
gemacht hat so heißt es in der
übersetzung dort von dem bekannt war und
wo er wusste dass es den vorwurf des
sexuellen missbrauchs
man soll mir männer sexuell missbraucht
haben im parlament
mit mitarbeiter und auch andere und das
habe boris johnson gewusst und das war
dann wirklich zu viel auch das noch das
war das schon zu viel und das kann dann
selbst ein typ wie sonst mit einem
unendlichen eu also so recht vom mond
und zurück
selbst das konnte er nicht mehr
aussetzen also boris johnson am ende
seiner karriere als premierminister
wer als nächstes dann folgen wird danke
dir peter g